I am proudly so so you're a murder
terrorist I'm a murder terrorist because
are a terrorist who did I murder because
if you're a Zion okay if I say I'm Isis
what does that mean it means you support
the ideas of Isis what Isis do I support
the idea of Z to kill innocent people I
don't support okay the Z wait wait the
humanitarian
aism wait wait wait wait wait the
the have killed thousands of children
and women say I'm proud theist that you
are terrorist you are a terrorist
terrorist and you are terrorist
terrorist anyone terrorist okay I'll
tell you a terrorist someone who
supports okay someone who kill innocent
people or someone who support not
someone who kill innocent people okay
are you educated are you stupid you are
are you stupid way you look I'm not
stupid are you more stupid than the way
you look you seem really intell you seem
more stupid we look someone who kills
innocent people is not a terrorist who
said that me who face
you're an
idiot speak ID I'm going to speak for 60
seconds don't allow idiot
speak second idiot I'm not allow here if
I kill someone with my car if I kill
someone idiot I'm not allowed here
Christ
sake all here I'm not going to listen to
a Zionist little dog you're a little dog
zist that's what I'm going to call you
for this guy supports of Zionist who are
killing children and women and he said
this proudly so therefore we don't speak
to Isis how are you Isis you okay can I
can can I talk no ID don't speak here
would anyone like to just hear what I
have to say no we
don't no take out yourself no
no no I want to talk to this guy to
me I don't want to talk to you I don't
want I don't want to talk someone
I
do don't you're Li you're deceiver no
I'm
not I'm to
[Music]
you you are and you
Palestinian a parado that doesn't make
any sense what's your name what's your
name I don't like idiot sorry my I don't
like
idiots don't like idiots why are you
filming this guy doesn't listen to
anybody himself okay we to fil you go
over there no listen guys listen listen
don't allow IDI people
some
speak is not Jesus Christ is not the
prophet of
Islam guys guys I am a very decent human
being who believes in gism would you
like to hear what got to say no we don't
why not keep quiet to keep quiet okay do
you care about the pal
people whenever you boo me when you boo
me you're what you're doing is you are
putting another nail in the coffin of
the future of the Palestinian people are
suppor come on man why don't you listen
why you let me I told you I don't like
to listen to idiot people my because
you're a zist and we're not going to
allow you to spread guys you're just
talking to yourself we are happy with it
is your problem okay how's it working
out for the Palestinian people this is
the problem of the mindset of of the
white supremacist why he's we talking to
ourselves what is your issue what is
your problem our the reason that the
white supremacist inv Africa to anything
you you just want to listen to yourself
talking okay why you listen to me
then if I'm talking I'm trying to
trying to persuade you to open your mind
another way of
understand your Isis supporter if you
support if you support a zist by Def you
support Isis rubbish stop talking if you
they agree with
you of guys guys how can I get you open
your
mind open your mind I a Zionist and I
ask something interesting to say you yes
they do you w listen to me I not a
terrorist I am a Zionist and I'm proudly
so let me explain to you why Mist all
right right put your hand up if you
think that if you kill an innocent
person you're a terrorist
your oh intentionally of course an
intentional okay that's not true either
that's our definition right if you think
that if you've got somebody shooting at
you and you shoot back at them and
they're holding a baby yes and the guys
is that terrorism terrorism I'm in I'm
in a fight you're a fight yeah and
you're going to kill me and all my
friends or I kill you but I have to kill
a baby who you're holding a baby and I
kill you and I kill a baby is that
terrorism no is that
terrorism if you done ter I don't agree
with you you're right or wrong enough if
you done it intentionally by killing the
baby you are terrorist no I know I'm
going to have to kill the baby I'm going
to have to kill the baby to kill the
terrorist are doing are killing children
claiming so you see what he tried to do
he tried to justify the king of the
Zionist of the children by claim listen
I don't know if you know about history
history tell us even the Bible are you
Christian by the way or Jewish or are
you you don't mind
asking are you're a Jewish okay if
you're a Jewish then according to the
Old Testament Palestine belongs to the
Palestinians you can't took over and you
K people children I think I think
Zionism I think Zionism founded was
founded on on um all sorts of atrocities
the and and the local Arab you want a
country you want a country sorry as a
Zionist you want a country correct you
want a land you want a country then go
to Germany the Germans kill you not us
go to Germany as to give you a land you
Palestinian I am Palestinian Pakistani
Algerian Egyptian I'm a Muslim every
Muslim country is my country that's it
that Mak me
like countries my
islamically speaking I'm from every
Muslim country that's what it teaches us
you know we Muslims we are like one body
okay if any part of the body feel pain
the rest of the body feel pain okay wait
wait wait you said to me about the child
what is known even by the United Nations
okay even other non-islamic non-arab
organizations they are saying clearly
what the Zionist are doing is Terrorism
act they are killing innocent people yes
you check it out all right answer this
question that's why the court wait
International Court in South Africa they
put what they put out a warrant and
guess they do not put a warrant they not
put a warrant your fact right no come on
man no
warrant for a warrant it's not actual
same kitchen different food no it's not
yes same kitchen different
food let me ask you a question if we ask
me a question you follow the Bible I
follow the Bible yes of course I don't
follow the Bible the Bible's an ancient
heral
VI I'm a proud Jew but Jews don't follow
the Bible
we we follow the
rabbi yeah the Torah is in the Old
Testament T no the Torah is not the
Bible the Quan you don't follow the
Quran
follow of it yeah of
it they believe in some book and they
reject some
don't that anyway so what finish what do
you think about in the Tor when he says
to kill a woman and children I think
it's disgusting and awful so go do you
believe in God by the way do I believe
in God what does you mean do I believe
what the hell is God what are you
talking
about where is God what is God I think
you're more confused than confused at
all you're more confused than confus I
don't believe so an atheist that's I'm
not an atheist do you believe in god
what do you mean by God creator
everything what is that what is the
creative oh wait wait wait you all
brilliant people have been to theology
school and you all know what God is no I
tell you what God is ridiculous no we
just told you God is undefinable he's a
he or she or it
complet we have no idea what God is God
is incomprehensible to human being so
you the RAB that's what God is so you
for the rabbis yes rabbis they have no
problem with the Tora says to kill
babies and children you the RAB they
don't show me the don't tell me the
secular rabis no show me proper rabbis
come on show me okay when's the last
time when's the last time a rabbi yeah
or any Rabbi of any kind ever ever
taught that that that genocide is is
acceptable schy thinks genocide is okay
rubbish anyway prove it to me when when
did he say
that a lie listen listen before you tell
me I'm going to prove it to you with a
logical rational that the rabbis they
genocide
okay in the wait wait wait in the Torah
there's many genocide and guess the non
jewi Jewish people yes yes there is okay
show me one show me one Rabbi said this
disting show show me show me show
me wait wait genci it's genocide it's
genocide it's genocide and crime next
victim pleas genocide crime victim pleas
hello crime is it okay for Hamas tode no
it's not it's not you're Pro you see
Muslim anti wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait are you Pro Ham let me
speak now tell you what I am as a Muslim
Islam teaches me to be just and to be
fair okay if Hamas kill women and
children is har
forbidden your sign released anyone got
a sign saying releas We Know listen
listen Muslim friends kidna
anding Hostage to women kidnapping he
kidnapped the whole palestin I don't
care the whole of
Palestine sorry brother I don't follow
the Western World meaning that let me
something no
longero correct you remember they in the
'90s they suer
7 you got put in prison they terrorist
or not no what is he now hero you can go
to lond the bridge and you see dispatch
of so when you tell me about listen let
me finish let me finish youate youate
you of course you have no right I'm not
humiliated at all I'm not educated at
all if you come to my country and you
take over my country am I not allowed to
defend my country yes if you lose you
have to give up no never never this is
what this is what what they try to do to
us in Africa they try to brainwash us
through the Bible that if you lose
except is teacher if you lose don't give
up keep trying keep trying you die
or very for no there's a time when we
have to have a peace the Muslims are not
able to defend themselves like you in
the Bible the Jewish people I mean look
I'll tell you something I have a note I
mentioned that before if you study
history very well Noah commit genocide
like the Jewish people that is in your
bible let me ask you a question do you
agree with that you think H you agre
with that I think the I think you agree
with that no I don't agree with that I
think genocide old test so the Old
Testament show us that there was many
genocides carried out by the Jewish
people one want talks about it okay let
me answer the question how I want to
answer it no no it's how how no you
don't decide how I answer questions I
I'm the boss no you're not the boss
you're nobody and so am I this guy's a
nobody he doesn't know anything he just
sh he doesn't know how to learn no
humility you don't know nothing okay I
agree with you I don't know nothing so I
should not be speaking why you why
should you be speaking so why you
speaking to me because I love
Palestinians I want them to be
free
freesian you see everybody here I
promise you I do and I tell you why I do
shut up and listen the reason care about
Palestinians I am a Zionist who loves
Palestinians let me tell you
something people but I love
H he's so clever isn't he you guys why
you right now the isra Army Palestinians
in and
youting it you don't actually care about
palan you don't care about you care
about hating Jews that's what you care
about
I'm not I'll tell you
why many people fight and the people of
Gaza are suffering there many people
fight and they're being killed and
they're being Ma and there many people
figh against you there's many people
figh against because you guys hate us
more than you love stop lying you your
own this could all stop right now hat
you there are hostages
EXC women hostages I'm not moving make
me I'm not moving aside let me I care
about Palestinians nor people stop
talking stop talking you don't give a
about
themy
angry angry innoc people surrender right
now stops we can make peace we can make
a beautiful Palestinian State the
Palestinian people are strong creative
beautiful people and they can build a
beautiful country but all they do by you
stop in and
Mur you guys
support why do you that says release the
hostages surrender surrender
[Applause]
Palestinian surrender you know what
that's what he wanted to say that's why
he for a long
time that's why he want say saw him time
you know Subhan Allah this guy he
reminds us of the story of Satan when he
came to Adam and he swore to Adam that
he want good for Adam this guy is a
Zionist and he's claiming that he cares
about the Palestinians that doesn't make
any sense he's like someone saying I
love Hitler but I care about the Jewish
people if you love H hit he killed them
he didn't like an example he go so angry
he become very frustrated so the point
here look what they want they want the
Muslims to keep up their country they
land okay so this is what they want so
this guy alhamdulillah the Zion is be
exposed even the Jewish people and gu
them there was in America New York even
London there was many Jewish people came
out protesting against Zionist you see
so the Zionist have noticed if you
expose them they pull out the card
anti-semitic I am a Semitic I'm not anti
myself you understand Semitic mean to be
an Arab to be an Israelite to be
likewise from the the nation of I know
Arab and Israelite but other nations too
the point here is he cannot utilize the
argument against me they want to kill
innocent people then when you expose
them they call you anti-semitic so
alhamdulillah we exposed him he got so
angry you know when I told him about the
Hitler jewi people he became upset
alhamdulillah goodd you know that's how
we defend palestin alhamdulillah we
don't have to be shouting free mixing
with women in the streets do now you
expose D alhamdulillah you make Dua you
donate alhamdulillah but as for doing
something of quannah will never give us
Victory will never give us a victory
victory learn how to expose these people
you know how on Earth this person us is
a Zionist on the other hand he say I
care about Palestinians how he cares
about Palestinians he exposed himself by
the Palestinians to give up their land
that's how he cares about them fulfill
all your rights yes that's it you know
Subhan Allah you know subh look how
Allah exposed him with his own tongue
you know so now that's why we don't
follow the Western the Western world is
confused as well sometimes they call
someone terrorist next day they call him
a hero they're always confused but we
Muslims always we are what consistent
cuz why our criter Quran Sunnah our
criter is not our feeling today he's a
terrorist tomorrow he's a hero no Quran
sunah is a criteria in Islam killing
innocent people killing children women
is Haram Prophet Muhammad said that in
theith clearly explicitly likewise we
not even allow you to go and even him as
a Zionist I'm not going to allow you to
go and attack him physically because a
Zionist you understand it's har Islam
except try to attack me will attack my
Muslim brother and sister in this
understand so because why in this
country there is a law we have to obey
the law as long the law doesn't oppose
Allah's law see subh Allah Islam so this
guy again aldah Allah exposed him
today and it's very important my dear
brothers and sisters to learn and study
we have to seek knowledge we have to
learn learn first learn the man first he
come back he come back he's back he's
back back round two round two you know
what you just did you expose Yourself by
saying you care about the Palestinians
how by giving their land you want
Palestinians to give up their land he
want the Palestinians to give up their
land that's how he cares about
them stop being you listen you and and
you are
sa your
why you support
terrorist
anyway real
terrorist important to seek knowledge to
learn
he's he's going to come up for round two
Al we have toar we have to
Studd and and a reminder my dear
brothers forget him now a reminder to
myself and to you when we in the winter
time or Autumn it's very important why
you can stop every remind that to all of
us you know Subhan Allah so
winter why the night is longer and the
day shorter so you easy to fast and easy
to pray night prayer so we should
utilize this time the winter time to
carry out Allah's worship to worship
Allah why we worship ship Allah not
because Allah is in need of our worship
because we are in need of Allah's
worship cuz without Allah we no will
never be able to survive and of the
outcome of our societies we are confused
why because we turn away from God when
we turn away from God by Def you fall
into contradiction you know so but when
you when you follow God's teaching you
will have a good life you will have a
happy life doesn't mean you're going to
become rich no cuz yes money is good no
doubt have money no doubt about it but
the true happiness doesn't mean you have
to have a money to to attain true
happiness cuz true happiness is to have
contentment and before that to be the
servant saave and the worship of Allah
when you are a worship of Allah and you
understand your purpose that's when you
understand that this life doesn't mean
nothing always Allah will Aid you to be
strong in this life and look at our
brothers and sisters in R even the
hardship that are going through they
still firm why because of Islam because
Islam alhamdulillah you know sometimes
Allah mentioned that before sometimes
Allah will send down a tri or a Calamity
upon us either because we are to test us
or because it's as a reminder and a
punishment okay so as a reminder for as
as a as a test to raise us more in Jenna
and as a as a reminder to turn back to
Allah so what's happened to Allah our
our brothers and sisters to us well to
reflect upon it by reflecting upon our
own
situation and understanding that there
is a way to have victory over our
enemies not by emotion based upon not
evidence cuz there's emotion which is
based upon evidence praiseworthy one and
there's emotion which is based upon no
evidence this blame worthy one this will
lead you to
Darkness so my point here is my my dear
brothers nice prayer fast
you know especially the time we're
living in we're too busy with social
media we're too busy with life so we
have to have a time for ourselves just
between us and
Allah how many of us going through
hardship pray a night prayer We complain
to everyone by pray night prayers you
know make to Allah let us read the Quran
you know us learn study our de you know
Al Islam is based upon knowledge Islam
is based
upon you know
and am the
way Allah forgive
us and don't forget you know unite us
upon the
truth upon the
truth you know uniting us upon for to
unite upon falsehood is B food no we
have to unite upon the
truth you know Quran theah and the way
of the Sal that's why I always advise my
dear brothers and sisters to seek
knowledge and study now some of us we
read one chapter next day we have a
YouTube channel uh
Tik Tok page and start giving
da it's not how you seek knowledge it's
not how you give